Кричущі випадки дискримінації виявили
у шкільних підручниках, які готуються до друку за держкошти.
Про це повідомляють у Міносвіти за підсумками роботи
антидискримінаційної експертизи, яка тривала з минулого року.
Вона знайшла і вилучила недопустимі висловлювання у підручниках
на кшталт "негри", "жиди", "цигани" тощо.
Виключатимуть і на перший погляд невинне слово "батьки".
Пов’язано це з тим, що в Україні, за даними МОН,
три мільйони дітей, а це близько сорока відсотків усіх дітей країни,
живуть нині у неповних сім’ях.
Вони мешкають або з дідусями та бабусями,
старшими братами чи сестрами, тітками або дядьками.
Фрази про батьків у підручниках
підкреслюють обмежені можливості майже половини українських дітей,
пояснюють у міністерстві.
Саме тому замість слова "батьки" вони радять вживати "рідні".
З цієї причини МОН виступає проти макетів підручників,
де зображені виключно повні родини.
Дискримінаційним експертиза вважає і стереотипне зображення
ролей хлопчиків і дівчат.
Наприклад, уявлення, що про дітей можуть піклуватися лише дівчата,
чи що технічними професіями
можуть займатися виключно хлопці.
Окрім того, експертиза виявила, що в підручниках повністю відсутні герої,
які представляють людей з інвалідністю.
Це при тому що, за статистикою, 6%  населення України
- близько двох з половиною мільйонів осіб -
це люди з інвалідністю.  А особи похилого віку
зображуються виключно немічними.
Зауваження антидискримінаційної експертизи
викликали неабияку реакцію у мережі.
Зокрема, деканша факультету Національного педагогічного університету
імені Драгоманова, називає такі дії гомодиктатурою
та наступом на класичну модель сім'ї.
Її матеріал, чомусь зі світлинами чоловіків, що цілуються, і голих сідниць,
про що жодним словом не йдеться у висновках експертизи,
викликав хвилю обурення у соцмережах.
Тим часом, згідно з підрахунками експертів,
в Україні підручників з ознаками гендерноїдискримінації
у старших класах - майже 80%.
Їх замінювуватимуть поступово, з друком нових підручників.